ce ministre on est toujours heureux de
vous accueillir
devant notre commission cette fois ci
donc pour évoquer le projet de loi
relatifs au développement solidaire et à
la lutte contre les inégalités mondiales
on va pas revenir sur la genèse
difficile compliqué de ce texte dont la
présentation a été maintes fois retardé
ce qui a du reste pour principale
conséquence d'en faire une loi de
programmation qui pour l'instant ne
programment que sur un an à savoir sur
l'année 2022
on me dit qu'il va y avoir des
changements sur ce sujet et peut-être
que vous ne vous en dirai plus ce texte
comporte toutefois de nombreux aspects
positifs dans certains répondent à des
recommandations formulées maintes fois
depuis plusieurs années par notre
commission et je veux saluer en la
matière les travaux d'henri de raincourt
hélène conway puis de jean pierre vial
et marie françoise pérol dumont dont nos
deux rapporteurs hugh laurie et rachid
kemal ont pris la relève depuis la fin
de l'année dernière ainsi les grands
principes de cette politique ou aux
quels nous sommes très attachés sont
réaffirmés dans un monde de plus en plus
chaotiques où certaines puissances
refuse de participer pleinement à la
communauté internationale cherchant sans
cesse à tirer avantage des crises qui se
succèdent sans répit la france quant à
elle tente de jouer sa partition en
soutenant le multilatéralisme et la
lutte contre les inégalités mondiales
nous sommes particulièrement attachés à
l'aide aux pays les plus pauvres
notamment sur le continent africain
auquel nous sommes liés par l'histoire
et dans lequel se concentre hélas bon
nombre des grands défis futurs a
maîtrisé nourrir soigner formés tel est
bien le triptyque prioritaire que ce
projet de loi doit mettre au centre de
notre action
sans négliger bien évidemment et les
défis environnementaux et les hommes et
les autres biens publics mondiaux qui
dorénavant constituent des x des
objectifs de premier plan
le projet doit s'efforcer également sans
toujours selon nous y parvenir
totalement de préciser l'organisation et
la gouvernance de cette politique
celle ci implique en effet deux
ministères ou moins deux agences live
des expertises france ainsi que de
multiples organismes de coordination du
conseil de développement au conseil
national développement de solidarité en
passant par le ciss idée par la cncd
votre choix monsieur le ministre a été
de conserver l'ensemble de ces couches
de gouvernance en tentant toutefois d'en
clarifier le positionne le
positionnement et le fonctionnement
on n'est pas encore totalement convaincu
sur cet aspect nous y reviendrons avec
les rapporteurs de la même manière il en
va des il en va de même de la reprise en
main de la gouvernance de l'aef des
lances sommes souvent entretenues
l'autonomie parfois excessives de
lagence ainsi que son activité très
orientée vers les prêts au bénéfice des
pays à revenu intermédiaire ont maintes
fois été souligne s est discutée ces
dernières années certaines des mesures
avancées par le projet apporte un début
de réponse
d'autres nous sans le parfois un peu
timoré enfin enfin vous savez
l'importance que nous accordons à
l'évaluation et au contrôle de cette
politique de développement solidaire il
s'agit d'argent public et nous sommes là
pour le contrôle et la création d'une
commission indépendante est une très
bonne chose et une avancée que nous
souhaitons saluer
reste à en définir plus précisément les
contours et à s'assurer que le parlement
puisse autant que le gouvernement
bénéficier pleinement de ces analyses
mais ce mini ce jeu vous propose de
prendre la parole pour un exposé
liminaire puis nous aurons nos deux
rapporteurs
hugh laurie est sans doute rachid tu es
mal qui est en visio en espérant qu'il
va mieux et nos autres collègues
pourront ensuite vous interrogez les
joueurs précise à nouveau que cette
audition est filmée et retransmise en
direct sur le site du sénat
monsieur le ministre vous avez la parole
alors monsieur le président mesdames
messieurs les sénatrices et sénateurs
enfin vous l'avez dit monsieur le
président cette cette loi était attendue
elle a été plusieurs fois repoussée mais
elle a eu cette singularité c'est que
d'une certaine manière les budgets
successifs l'ont un peu précédé par ces
leur réorientation et par leurs
fluctuations positive mais il fallait
organiser et structurer identifier nos
priorités et il est indispensable qu'ils
essaient de loi même si sa programmation
ne va que jusqu'en 2022
en termes chiffrés et bien identifiés
dans le texte qui vous est proposé et si
nous nous indiquons toujours à l'article
nous y reviendrons que il y aura une
réorientation chiffré aparté en 2022 sur
les échéances suivantes mais ça fait
partie aussi du débat des discussions
nous pourrons avoir tout cas je voudrais
remercier tous ceux qui ont depuis trois
ans travaillé à l'aboutissement de ce de
ce texte est je dirais que même si on a
pris du retard il se trouve que la
convergence de la discussion de cette
loi avec la crise que nous traversons
est significative de l'interdépendance
dans laquelle nous vivons et des enjeux
des biens communs qui sont aujourd'hui
au centre de des crises de notre planète
que ce soit sur la santé ou sur
l'environnement
et cette situation rend la solidarité et
l'entraidé et la coopération encore plus
nécessaire que auparavant moi je suis
frappé
je le dis parce que vous m'avez un petit
orienté vers l'homme si le président je
suis frappée du fait que l' influence
nous que nous vivons dans un monde de
compétition exacerbé que l' influence
est devenue un enjeu de puissance
majeure j'ai dit à nombreuses reprises
qu'il n'y avait plus de hargne et de
soft power il n'y avait que des
instruments d'influencé et donc de
puissance et que le développement est
devenu un enjeu d'un fluence et qu' il
faut prendre conscience de cela y
compris un enjeu dans la conflit qualité
des modèles des valeurs et ça rend ce
texte d'autant plus pertinent dans le
moment que nous traversons donc il
fallait revenir dans le jeu je pense que
nous sommes revenus dans le jeu puisque
maintenant notre aide publique au
développement a dépassé les 10 milliards
d'euros par an en 2020 nous allons être
sans doute à près de 13 milliards 12
milliards 8 à peu près d'après les
chiffres que je peux avoir
à cet instant et donc c'est un
changement de braquet de notre politique
de développement en termes de chiffres
conformément à l'engagement pris par le
président de la république dès le début
de son mandat nous allons porter note
'aaa' pda 0,55 d'autres richesses
nationales en 2022
c'était à 0,38 en 2016 je vous rappelle
ça montre l'effort qui a été parcouru
et aujourd'hui c'est on estime que le
rapport est à 0,48 et nous avons tenu à
maintenir notre engagement y compris
dans la crise actuelle y compris en
volume puisque notre à continuera
d'augmenter en volume de plus de 18%
entre 2019 et 2020 de plus de 33% entre
2020 et 2021 et je pense qu'on de cette
année mais il faudra attendre les bilans
effectués par l' ocde je pense que cette
année nous allons dépasser le royaume
uni ne placer au quatrième rang mondial
des bailleurs d'habitude en revenant
dans le jeu mais il s'agit pas
uniquement de faire plus
grâce à ses moyens renforcés nous
entendons aussi faire mieux
ce projet de loi il ne bureau si un
changement de méthode en profondeur dans
le sillage des efforts de rénovation qui
ont été engagées depuis le cid
le comité interministériel de la
coopération internationale et
développement de février 2018 c'est un
nouveau paradigme que je souhaite mettre
en oeuvre avec des priorités clairement
définies dans les priorités clairement
défini des priorités géographiques
nous allons concentrer notre aide
publique au développement en dons en
particulier vers les pays les plus
vulnérables en particulier les 19 pays
prioritaires appartenant à la catégorie
des pays les moins avancés
principalement situés en afrique
subsaharienne
ces pays sont son destinataire de la
moitié des leds projets mis en oeuvre
par mon ministère que ce qu'on appelle
les faits ce pays il doté de cette année
de 70 millions d'euros
et ces pays bénéficieront des deux tiers
de l'aide projets mis en oeuvre par
l'afd au total de total des ailes projet
de l'aef des étangs de 816 millions
d'euros en crédits de paiement en 2021
et nous allons aussi renforcer notre
soutien aux pays les moins avancés grâce
à l'augmentation de 10% de notre
contribution à l'association
internationale de développement de la
banque mondiale pour les mêmes objectifs
c'est à dire la priorité géographique
assez 19 pays que nous privilégions
considérés comme les plus les plus
vulnérables 19 filles 18 d'afrique
subsaharienne plus haïti priorités
géographiques priorités thématiques
partout où nous investissons que ce soit
dans les pays en développement mais
aussi dans les pays émergents nous
voulons investir dans l'avenir et dans
nos biens communs ce qui veut dire vous
avez dit monsieur brillant nourrir forme
est soigné ce qui veut dire là
aujourd'hui le renforcement des systèmes
de santé primaires
dans les pays les plus fragiles et
notamment dans la formation des
personnels de santé autour de l'ensemble
de ce que nous avons initié dans le
cadre de l'initiative santé en commun
qui a permis d'améliorer la prise en
charge des malades au sénégal en guinée
au burkina faso ont versé à à travers le
soutien aux ong à lima qui a permis de
renforcer le laboratoire de référence de
l'institut pasteur
donc nous sommes dans une mobilisation
autour de ce bien commun qu'est
l'ensemble du système de santé en
particulier la lutte contre la pandémie
pour prendre un exemple de l'actualité
actuelle dans les priorités thématiques
il s'agit aussi d'investir dans la
préservation du climat et de la
biodiversité grâce à l'augmentation
notera depuis 2010 est nous avons pu
doubler notre contribution au fonds vert
pour le climat
1 milliard 500 millions d'euros sur la
fin du processus de notre doublement de
participation sourd sur trois ans passe
de 700 on avait investi 750 millions 12
notre anticipation de 750 millions sur
trois ans ce qui nous permet d'ailleurs
de renforcer notre crédibilité et notre
engagement diplomatique dans les
enceintes multilatérales dans ça ne sert
à rien de dire qu'on va être acteur pour
aboutir un bon résultat de la coop 26 si
nous mêmes ne sommes pas intervenants un
haut niveau dans les instances
multilatérales dans ce domaine et
l'urgence environnementale est une
priorité absolue
cinq ans après l'accord de paris au
seuil d'une année 2021 qui va être
déterminante puisque cette année sera
l'année du congrès de l'union
internationale pour la conservation de
la nature qui va se tenir à marseille
cette année ce sera aussi l'année de la
coop vensys commence à se préparer et
qui aboutira à glasgow et c'est aussi
l'année de la cop15 sur la biodiversité
de kooning en chine qui sera aussi un
élément politique est majeur pour pour
la planète sur pour cette rubrique de la
lutte pour la préservation du climat et
la biodiversité les financements de
l'afd
sont bien sûr tous compatibles avec
l'accord de paris mais nous nous sommes
engagés à ce que la moitié des
financements du groupe f des contribuer
directement en plus de leur finalité
première à l'atteinte des objectifs de
l'accord c'est ce qu'on appelle les
financements cours-bénéfice climat par
exemple lorsque nous participons à la
construction d'un nouveau tramway dans
une ville va nous faisons d'une paire de
coûts nous agissons à la fois pour
faciliter la vie de ses habitants pour
le développement de la ville mais en
même temps pour le climat puisque les
transports publics permettent de réduire
les émissions de co2 autrement dit sur 2
euros de financement à fd il y à un euro
qui sert directement le combat contre
les règlements climatique ce qui est
quand même un chiffre très très
significatif
j'aurais dit d'ailleurs ici que ce
combat pour le climat pour une
croissance verte mais j'ai eu l'occasion
de l'évoquer
nous avons parlé du sahel en séance
plénière le sud de votre initiative
ce qu'on va nous le mènerons aussi au
coeur du sel avec le projet de la grande
muraille verte qui a été initié en 2007
qui était il y avait un peu retombée
c'était une initiative très forte à ce
moment là et que le one man show met du
mois de janvier dernier que nous avons
organisée a permis de relancer en
mobilisant 14 milliards de dollars sur
l'avenir pour renforcer la résilience
des populations face aux crises
climatiques et permettent de lutter
contre la désertification avec des
projets ponctuels permettant de
stabiliser les populations et de
développer les aires naturelles
protégées dans le massif du tibesti au
tchad par exemple on le fait
actuellement
ou par l'art préparer introduction de la
casse hier dans les zones dégradées au
nord sénégal ou par les projets de
l'agroécologie au burkina faso bref
cette logique là commence à se remettre
en mouvement et nous sommes je suis
particulièrement attaché à bien faire
aboutir ce gigantesque projet qui va
nous tenir plus plusieurs années mais il
faut qu'on puisse le développer en
projets concrets sur or particulier sur
la zone sahélienne n'est pas uniquement
puisque la grande muraille verte va de
du sénégal à djibouti
ce combat pour le climat nous menons
aussi je le dis parce que je sais que
c'est un sujet qui vous sur lequel vous
êtes très vigilants nous mais non aussi
dans d'autres pays qui sont des pays
émergents le combat pour le climat et je
pense entre autres à la chine et à la
turquie équidés sont des sujets que nous
avons souvent abordés ensemble et je
dois de vous dire ici on peut être par
anticipation des discussions que nous
pourrons avoir que les prêt non
concessionnel accordé par l'afd à ces
pays ne sont en aucun cas une faveur ce
sont des prêts que qui sont accordées au
taux en vigueur sur le marché mais avec
des priorités qui sont les priorités que
je viens d'évoquer en particulier les
priorités sur l'engagement climatique
investir dans l'avenir de nos biens
communs
je parle des priorités à mettre en avant
c'est aussi investir dans l'éducation
nous sommes aujourd'hui le troisième
bailleur mondial en faveur de
l'éducation avec une multiplication par
dix d'une contribution au partenariat
mondial pour l'éducation de 100 millions
d'euros sur 2018 2020 et il faudra se
remobiliser rapidement puisque le
le programme mondial pour l'éducation le
partenariat mondial pour l'éducation va
se tenir cette année et il va y avoir
une conférence de reconstitution des
ressources mais cet engagement donne des
résultats significatifs tout à fait
indispensable je pense en particulier au
fait que ce partenariat mondial pour
l'éducation a soutenu la scolarisation
de plus de 22 millions d'enfants et
c'est particulièrement sensible dans les
19 pays que j'ai évoqué tout à l'heure
enfin la dernière priorité c'est la
promotion de l'égalité de genre comment
sont justement par l'égalité entre les
filles et les garçons à l'école et c'est
aussi un gage de stabilité de peau notre
société nous aborderons ces enjeux lors
du forum génération égalité qui se
tiendra dans quelques mois à paris sous
la présidence conjointe donnée d'onu
femmes et de la france il s'agit indiqué
les priorités géographiques j'ai indiqué
les priorités thématiques il faut les
traiter ensemble non plus dans une
approche on en silo par la crise du
cofide à montrer leur enchevêtrement et
donc à rappeler la nécessité pour nous
de mettre en oeuvre une approche
transversale
je parlais de nouveaux paradigmes
ce sont aussi des partenariats refonder
il s'agit plus seulement de faire pour
nos partenaires du sud
il s'agit de faire avec eux pour une
raison très simple c'est que nous devons
faire recette émaner du co-développement
parce que nous avons des responsabilités
communes des intérêts communs et nous
devons l'assumer pleinement donc sommes
pas dans une logique d'assistance de
charité si je peux utiliser ce terme de
manière négative ce qui n'est pas
généralement mon habitude il s'agit de
faire en sorte que nous parlions de
développement solidaire en aidant nos
partenaires de suite nous nous et donc
nous mêmes car les réponses aux grandes
questions du 21e siècle se trouve à la
fois chez nous et chez eux et donc il
nous faut retrouver un cercle vertueux
je pense par exemple aux défis des
migrations irrégulières et des tragédies
humaines qu'ils occasionnent
on ne peut faire face à ce défi qu'en
aidant la jeunesse du sud a retrouvé des
perspectives d'avenir qui ne passe ni
par le déchirement du départ ni parle
des routes de la nécessité là encore
nous avons des responsables
été et des intérêts en commun et ceux de
renforcement de la dimension
partenariale de notre politique
développement est essentiel
elle se joue aussi en france et ce
partenariat va se traduire
vous n'avez pas évoquer monsieur le
président je voudrais le dire ici parce
qu'il est très important par le fait que
les acteurs de la société civile
française se verront reconnaître un
droit d'initiative qu'il qui leur
permettra de proposer eux-mêmes des
projets et le fonds de soutien de l'état
aux organisations de la société civile
et aux collectivités territoriales
seront doublés entre 2017 et 2022 nous
rapprochons ainsi de la moyenne du
comité des de développement de l' ocde
et nous voulons associer aussi à nos
efforts les diasporas africaines en
france parce que nous considérons
qu'elles ont un rôle crucial à jouer
dans la nouvelle relation que nous
voulons initier avec l'afrique et seront
elles gagnent elles mêmes au coeur du
prochain sommet afrique france qui se
tiendra en juillet à montpellier nouveau
paradigme par un partenariat renouvelé
nouveau paradigme aussi par un
renforcement du pilotage de la politique
de développement du développement par
l'état avec une chaîne de commandement
et de responsabilité je crois que larry
fiez vous interrogez monsieur le
président sur ce sujet on va pouvoir
parler mais je crois clarifier du plus
haut niveau de l'état avec le conseil
présidentiel du développement qui donne
les grandes orientations que
la france veut voir mettre en oeuvre
dans sa politique de développement jusqu
au plus près du terrain grâce à une
implication renforcée de nos ambassades
et s'est inscrit dans la loi et c'est ce
que je crois les uns les autres vous
souhaitiez une nous souhaitions tout cas
c'est ce que je souhaitais aussi
personnellement c'est le sens des
conseils locaux de développement que
nous allons créer dans chaque poste
singulièrement dans les dix neuf postes
concernés par les 19 pays que je viens
d'évoquer
ils sont présidées sur notait le terrain
par notre ambassadrice où notre
ambassadeur il veille à la cohérence des
efforts de l'ensemble des acteurs de
l'équipe france du développement
présents dans un pays donné
y compris bien sûr l'afd dans le cadre
d'une stratégie qui décline nos grandes
priorités en fonction des réalités
locales et en tenant compte de la
programmation européenne et de l'action
des autres bailleurs internationaux
je peux me permettre de donner un
exemple d'abord j'ai fait j'ai fait
savoir qu'une fois que ce texte sera
voté mais même en anticipation à chaque
déplacements que j'effectuerai dans les
19 pays concernés mais aussi dans les
autres
je tiendrai je présiderai moi même le
conseil de développement avec
l'ambassadeur ou l'ambassadrice et je
souhaite aussi que soient associés dans
ces conseils de développement
je sais plus si c'est dans le texte ou
pas après la discussion qu'on a eue à
l'assemblée en tout cas c'est un souhait
les autres acteurs du développement pas
uniquement français qui sont partie
prenante de projets structurants
j'ai pu me j'ai pu le fait pas parce
qu'il faut de la cohérence
j'ai pu le faire comment j'ai fait il
faut le faire j'ai fait un peu peuvent
de laboratoire la semaine vendredi
dernier à niamey puisque c'était le
l'installation du nouveau président
monsieur bazoum qui remplace le
président issoufou et j'en ai profité
pour réunir autour de l'ambassadeur les
acteurs du développement n'est pas
uniquement le français y compris la
déléguée l'union européenne y compris
ceux qui sont acteurs sur dans le
territoire je pense en particulier en ce
qui concerne
le niger l'ambassadeur d'allemagne ces
outils ça pour voir comment est-ce qu'on
avance ensemble y compris les acteurs
locaux qui sont directement liés au
processus parce que il faut du
développement une politique intégrée du
développement qui soit vraiment au coeur
de la vie et des enjeux locaux et non
pas une politique en silo alors nous
étions un peu spécialiste de la
politique en silo au niveau mondial
c'est extrêmement généralisée et si on
n'a pas une politique concrète d'enjeux
territoriaux on passera à côté d'où
l'intérêt d'un enjeu grande très
mobilisateur d'abord une grande muraille
verte mais aussi l'intérêt d'avoir des
opérations ponctuelles en cohérence les
uns avec les autres
voilà c'était les mots qui tout à fait
tout à fait essentiel par ailleurs dans
jeu suite à nos débats j'ai beaucoup
appris dans les observations que vous
m'aviez fait aussi organise tous les
deux mois une réunion de cadrage avec le
directeur général de l'afd
depuis maintenant un an pour m'assurer
que les orientations politiques j'ai
défini se traduisent par des crédits
budgétaires significatif et que le
parlement vote chaque année les
orientations et que ses orientations
soient effectivement mises en oeuvre des
projets concrets sur le terrain et cet
exercice me permet peut-être que je le
fais avec peut-être un peu trop
d'enthousiasmé en tout cas pas de
naïveté
cet exercice ne permet elle je pense
maintenant de piloter en temps réel
lagence ici et sur les territoires
quand je me rends compte tenu de
l'importance des efforts consentis et de
ses enjeux considérables
il s'agit aussi de mieux mesurer
l'impact des projets que nous
accompagnons c'est pour ça que nous
avons souhaité que le projet de loi
intègre la création d'une commission
indépendante d'évaluation comme il en
existe déjà au royaume uni et en
allemagne et j'ai pris cette initiative
à la suite de discussions que nous avons
pu avoir ici et en séance plénière au
sénat
ce sit in au départ je crois une
proposition sénatoriale
il conviendra
que cette commission se prononce sur
l'efficacité
les résultats est l'impact réel d'une
politique de développement en évaluant
les stratégies en évaluant les
instruments de l'aide bilatérale et
multilatérale mais aussi des projets en
cours et il appartiendra qu'elles
formulent des recommandations à
l'attention du gouvernement et des
opérateurs c'est ce n'est pas la
vérification du fait que le les budgets
sont bien tenues que les budgets sont
bien réalisés c'est la vérification
d'une dévaluation que la politique menée
est opportune efficace et donne des
résultats
c'est pas le même sujet la demande forte
ce n'est pas de vérifier les comptes il
ya des organismes qui font ça très bien
les demandes fortes mais on les a bien
la boîte c'est d'évaluer la pertinence
des opérations et la réelle mise en
oeuvre de ces opérations de ses actions
et je souhaite que cette commission
puisse faire ce rapport devant le
parlement
parce que c'est bien là que la marche
des politiques publiques conduites en au
nom de la république doit pouvoir se
vérifier c'est selon l'appel ça
aujourd'hui de la redevabilité et bien
un constat de la redevabilité moi je
suis vous m'avez interrogé sur un peu
sur le jeu croit les rapporteurs aussi
sur la le contenu de la commission il ya
eu un débat à l'assemblée nationale sur
le sujet mais je suis très ouvert ce que
je souhaite c'est qu'elle soit
indépendante parce qu'autrement vaut pas
le coup d'exister qu'elle soit
indépendante qu'elle soit autonome par
rapport au gouvernement par rapport aux
acteurs et qu'elle puisse porter un
jugement donc du coup il faut à mon avis
qu'elle soit plus rama fondre à
l'occasion de reparler peut-être tout à
l'heure où dans le débat public
quelles sont peut être ramassé qu'elles
soient pertinentes dans sa composition
en tout cas c'est dans cet état d'esprit
que je veux travailler
enfin ce projet de loi comporte un volet
attractivité qui permettra de renforcer
la capacité de la france à attirer les
organisations les fondations
internationales dont beaucoup occupe un
rôle central dans l'agenda mondial du
développement et dans la promotion des
biens publics mondiaux
en fait cette initiative que vous avez
qui qui peut paraître un peu étonnante
un endroit où elle est placée mais là
une raison particulière c'est le suis
rendu compte que les organismes
multilatéraux dont nous avons été à
l'initiative
je pense à unitel je pense au fonds
mondial qui est décrit par chirac à un
moment donné je pense à la fondation
halliche qui est écrit par le présent
hollande
ces structures ne font pas le choix de
s'installer en france et vont
s'installer à genève pour une raison
simple c'est que dans l'état actuel du
droit français compte tenu de la
lourdeur des procédures nécessaires à
l'octroi des privilèges et immunité
fiscale normal des organisations
internationales
virement les organisations liées au
développement on met un temps fou et
donc il faut s'installer là où c'est
plus les plus rapides et c'est la raison
pour laquelle nous proposons que nous
puissions légiférer par ordonnances sur
chaque cas évidemment ensuite c'est le
processus législatif normal qui conduit
à vous soumettre un projet de loi pour
ratifier l'accord de siège lorsque celui
ci ait été trouvé pour aller plus vite
et faire en sorte que la france puisse
devenir un carrefour mondial de la
coopération internationale ce que nous
pouvons devenir puisque les trois
premières éditions du forum de paris sur
la paix ont montré que nous avions une
capacité de mobilisation très
significative
enfin pour terminer vous savez que
l'examen de ce texte par l'assemblée
nationale a permis de l'enrichir de
manière significative
je sais que vous aurez sans doute aussi
vous même à coeur de l'améliorer pour
mémoire le texte issu des travaux de
l'assemblée introduit trois dispositions
majeures d'abord un nouvel article 1er
fixant les grands objectifs de la
politique de développement dans le texte
de loi et non dans le seul rapport
annexé qui s'appelle le cas de
partenaire global
par les députés ont voulu qu'il y ait un
article premier qui fixe les grands
objectifs lors cet article rappelle en
particulier je crois que c'est le point
le plus important qui reprend ce que je
lisais en commençant la politique de
développement est un pilier de la
politique étrangère de la france
c'est essentiel et la politique
étrangère de la france
la politique de développement
contribuent à construire assurer la paix
la sécurité en complément de l'action
diplomatique et d'action militaire et
souvenirs l'importance accordée la
promotion de l'égalité entre les femmes
et les hommes dans le cadre de la
diplomatie féministe inscrits dans le
dans le texte de loi
comme j'ai fait de ce diplomatie
féminisme des mes priorités je me suis
trouvé tout à fait à l'aise dans les
propositions qu'on puisse faire les
députés à ce sujet donc un nouvel
article ific des consos festif de la
politique de développement deuxièmement
il y a eu 1 inscriptions avec mon accord
l'article relatif à la programmation
financière d'une date cible à 2025 pour
l'atteinte des 0,7 conformément à
l'objectif onusien ce n'était pas le cas
au début mais je pense que l'objectif de
reprise de la résolution des nations
unies de mois novembre 62 9 en 1970
inscrivant cet objectif des 0,7 en 2025
me paraît un bon objectif et nous devons
nous mobiliser là dessus donc c'est une
amélioration la quantitativement très
très significatif qui a été validée qui
a obtenu qui a vu mon accord lorsque le
député berville d'autres parlementaires
l'ont proposé enfin troisième 3ème
dispositions nouvelles proposées par les
députés l'amélioration du dispositif de
restitution des produits de cession d
dite des biens mal acquis
alors cette cette disposition fait lever
la double amendements parlementaires et
gouvernementales mais je sais qu'ici il
ya eu des travaux qui ont été menés à ce
sujet en particulier par le sénateur
jean-pierre sueur mais sans doute aussi
d'autres ce nouveau dispositif prévoit
que les produits de cession des biens
mal acquis
dans les contours en référence au code
pénal sont précisément définir dans la
loi de grand lieu à deux ouvertures de
crédit au sein d'un nouveau programme
budgétaire qui sape qui sera placé sous
la responsabilité au sein du ministère
des affaires étrangères en vue de
financer des actions de coopération et
de développement c'est une grande
innovation
il ya plusieurs modalités possibles pour
la mise en oeuvre pourrait
éventuellement en parler en tout cas
cela devra se faire dans une parfaite
transparence et héros de l'habilité
devant le parlement puisque ce sera
inscrit au budget du ministère des
affaires étrangères dès qu'il y aura des
possibilités et ça reviendra directement
populations qui ont été spoliés par les
gays malek
enfin le texte prévoit des avancées en
matière ne fallait les députés ont
proposé des avancées en matière de
redevabilité avec la création d'une base
de données ouverte avec l'élargissement
du champ du rapport annuel au parlement
relatifs à la politique de développement
on y reviendra et le texte précise
également que la commission indépendante
d'évaluation de l'aide publique au
développement sera placé auprès de la
cour des comptes et il prévoit la
possibilité pour le parlement de saisir
la commission de demandes d'évaluation
venu du parlement et un décret viendra
préciser les modalités de fonctionnement
de cette commission
il y a eu deux autres points je le
précise tout de suite qui pour éviter
d'y revenir après trois 3 autres points
moins en moins majeur que les trois
principaux tant que je viens d'évoquer
qui ont été portées par les députés qui
ont fait l'objet d'ajouts d'abord la
prison compte pas la france de
l'exigence de la responsabilité
sociétale des acteurs publics et privés
sur le devoir de vigilance des
entreprises quand une entreprise a une
filiale qui travaillent dans le
signifiant la question se pose mais ça
peut arriver ailleurs
d'autre part il ya une volonté de
renforcer l'axé un état civil fiable
dans les priorités de
du développement en particulier dans le
cadre la promotion des droits de
l'enfant
enfin le gouvernement devra remettre au
parlement un rapport spécifique sur les
dispenses de criblage des bénéficiaires
finaux
peut-être qu'on enverra la discussion
pour pour l'instant il ya des critères
qui sont bien définis sur ce qui est de
l'ordre de l'humanitaire qui n'est pas
criblé et ce qui est de l'or du
développement qui est criblé mais il ya
une zone grise entre les deux et sur
lequel c'est assez difficile de donner
une définition stricte et donc il faut
qu'il y ait un rapport qui précise pour
en particulier les ong dans des
situations de crise perdre persistante
comment est ce qu'on peut faire pour
agir
et enfin il ya eu a été proposé une
réduction des coûts de transaction des
transferts de fonds effectués par des
personnes résidant en france vers des
personnes résidant dans les états
éligibles à la pdc de 19 pays concernés
et une observation sur la stratégie de
la france en matière de mobilité
internationale en entreprise en
administration sur pour les volontaires
internationaux qui ne soit pas que ça ne
serve pas de deux fausses couvertures
pour des activités lucratives
tout ça a fait l'objet d'un grand une
longue discussion à l'assemblée
nationale et à vous qui comme vous le
savez un vote à l'unanimité après un
long débat très fructueux et très très
positifs et qui je pense renforce
l'image de la france du fait que je
crois que c'est le seul texte
depuis le début du quinquennat qui a été
voté à l'unanimité par l'assemblée
nationale
merci monsieur lui nice de l'ensemble de
cette présentation il ya un certain
nombre de points qui
sont 12 à entendre pour ceux qui
demandent notamment en matière
d'évaluation et de contrôle de
véritables dispositifs je crois qu'on va
dans le bon sens là aussi sur la
gouvernance mais ceci va être repris par
le rapporteur je vous propose
d'organiser la discussion de la manière
suivante on va entendre les deux
rapporteurs de la commission puis les
deux rapporteurs de la commission des
finances que je vois vous répondrez aux
rapporteurs puis après on aura le les
questions cribles une minute une
question sur longue liste de mes
collègues qui se sont inscrits à la
routine des rapporteurs qui auront la
lourde responsabilité de présenter le
texte donc tout d'abord xori je voudrais
simplement au passage associés d'abord
la mémoire de marielle de sarnez qui
avaient beaucoup travaillé avec nous et
avec moi notamment sur la préparation
de ce texte je voulais que ce nom soit
cité
hughes merci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre
donc je rapporte le texte avec mon
collègue racheter malki qui en visio et
qui à quelques questions également comme
moi vous posez donc est la suite d'abord
je voudrais vous vous remercier pour
votre disponibilité qui a permis un
dialogue direct à plusieurs reprises
avec vous même ou avec vos services ou
votre votre cabinet cela a été dit par
le par le président et par vous même
c'est un projet de loi qui a été
retardée assez fortement mais qui s'est
accéléré fort heureusement depuis ce que
je crois qu'il a été présenté au mois de
décembre en conseil des ministres et
donc au mois de mai il aura été discutée
à la fois devant l'assemblée nationale
et devant le et devant le sénat
peut-être pour mes collègues dire que
c'est un texte de loi qui est finalement
assez court une qui ne comporte que très
article mais qui est structuré avec un
rapport annexé dénommé cadre de
partenariats de partenariat global qui
lui assez assez touchés et c est assez
long c'est un texte qui est il me paraît
ouvert où il me semble qu'ils
manifestent une volonté de votre part
d'être à l'écouté d'un ensemble de
remarques qui avaient été formulées fois
ici et ailleurs et je vous en remercie
il acte différents points importants qui
constitue incontestablement une avancée
alors ils ont été cités je vais pas
revenir mais on pourrait parler donc de
l'augmentation conséquente des budgets
des pays prioritaires et des pays les
moins avancés pays prioritaires qui sont
clairement définis dans le texte des
précisions également sur la répartition
dont près une commission attendu
indépendante d'évaluation qui est un
apport particulièrement intéressant et
puis les conseils locaux de
développement qui je pense sont
également sains
une structure qui va être mise en place
et qui
permettra d'avoir une aide française
plus efficace sur le terrain mais il
présente aussi certains points
d'amélioration que je vais évoquer
maintenant puisque c'est l'objet de
cette de cette réunion donc l'aide
publique au développement au sens de l'
ocde comporte des dépenses qui ne
relèvent pas à proprement parler de
cette politique de développement
solidaire et de lutte contre les
inégalités mondiales qui fait l'objet du
projet de loi par exemple les dépenses
pour les réfugiés en france ou encore
l'imputation des frais des étudiants
étrangers
ça c'est la définition de l' ocde c'est
pourquoi on se réfère fréquemment à ce
que le céder aux appels l'aide pays
programmable qui ne comprend que les
dépenses qui correspondent vraiment à la
mise en oeuvre de cette politique auprès
des pays aidés
il s'agit notamment des dons aux pays
les plus pauvres et des prêt de l'afd
or la part en proportion de notre aide
programmables bénéficiant aux pays les
moins avancés n'a fait que stagner voire
régresser passant de 20 % en 2014 à 18%
en 2018
cette part si on veut prendre des
exemples est de 39% au royaume uni 43 %
pays-bas 53% en suède
42 % aux etats-unis et si l'on prend les
pays prioritaires de notre aide qui
regroupe 19 de ces pma c'est le site
d'ailleurs celle ci ciblent 2013 qui
avait fixé et les deux tiers pour les
pays pro prix prioritaire de la part de
de la sd la part de notre est
programmable qui l'aurait dessinée est
encore plus faible
seulement 13% ceci signifie que 87 % de
notre aide programmables ne bénéficie
pas à nos pays prioritaires or sur ce
point le projet de loi ne comporte pas
d'objectif nouveau je disais à l'instant
que c'était le site 2013 qui avait fixé
cette barre à dos deux tiers de l'aide
de la part de l'afd ne serait-il pas
pertinent de fixer un objectif relatif à
l'aide programmables atteignable et
raisonnable pour remédier à cette
situation
dans le même ordre d'idée si on excepte
le japon la france singularise au sein
de ses pairs par une aide constitué pour
plus
moitié de près et par une part des deux
multilatéral très majoritaire alors même
que de très nombreux rapports qu'ils
soient parlementaires ou de la société
civile plaident pour un rééquilibrage
le projet de loi évoque ce sujet mais
sans objectifs chiffrés
là encore n'est-il pas temps de fixer un
objectif concret et raisonnable pour
infléchir la tendance
encore une fois ne s'agit pas de
préciser des objectifs qui figure déjà
dans la loi mais sans aucun chiffre à
ceux qui risquent d'amoindrir fortement
leur efficacité au fil du temps enfin la
situation des pays en développement a
beaucoup évolué depuis un an
d'un côté des pays très endettés qui
sont de plus en plus nombreux et
notamment en afrique où live des risque
ainsi de devoir encore diminuer ses
volumes de prêts avec d'ailleurs un
effet un peu pervers c'est que plus on
prête plus on attend un retour est donc
plus on s'intéresse à des pays qui ont
la capacité de rembourser et d'un autre
côté donc les taux d'intérêt restent bas
ce qui fait que les prêts proposés par
l'afd ne sont pas toujours compétitif
pour les pays à revenu intermédiaire
sachant qu'un certain nombre de pays
aujourd'hui ne consomme plus des prêts
mais des dons directement ce qui est
bien évidemment plus avantageux pour ces
pays
dès lors lagence ne doit-elle pas
changer de modèle voilà les trois
questions enfin les trois séries de
questions que je souhaitais vous posez
monsieur le ministre
merci hugues rachid tu es mal en visio
donc je vais compléter les propos de
nicolas une souris d'abord effectivement
souligné la qualité est ce qui nous est
proposé comme l'a dit mon collègue à la
fois chacun pu noter le retard mais
maintenant chacun
simon l'accélération retiendra dire que
c'est pape est d'ailleurs s'inscrit dans
le prolongement des lois précédentes de
côté dans le restant quinquennat il faut
pas l'oublier ce que ça aussi à ce
moment là est un moment important je
pars en ce qui concerne l'aide publique
au développement
il ya effectivement de vraies avancées
notamment je crois le fait de concentrer
le tir en janvier à son père est
l'expression sur les neufs pays
prioritaires notre et aussi de
concentrer sur son action et c'est vrai
que l'apport du nouvel article 1er me
semble essentiel même si eux nous
proposons quelques amandes d'éléments
dans le contexte mais je crois que c'est
important de repositionner à la fois les
priorités tant sur les thématiques que
sur les ailes partie géographique
je crois qu'il devrait avancer notamment
sur la question de la commission a
conduit je crois qu'il ya des choses
gens dire un mot sur la question des
idées et encore une fois ce qui est
important c'est que la france conserve
cette capacité conséquente de
d'intervenir et d'être un acteur majeur
sur la question les deux bouts je vais
essayer de me concentrer mon propos sur
quatre éléments
d'abord sur le pilotage de la politique
sweeting ensuite la question de la
taxation des transactions financières
la commission indépendante d'évaluation
et puis aussi un mot sur notre
programmation
d'abord sur le pilotage comme vous le
savez monsieur ministre et les sharks où
là il ya déjà eu un serment de deux en
matière de rapports sur les difficultés
rencontrées par le pilotage de la
politique de l'emploi solidaire en
particulier sur la question des rapports
parfois dit il négocie relations
inégales en collecte et c'est elle je
peux dire d'un mot la question qui a été
posée le temps pour la cour des comptes
qui indique que les outils de pilotage
on dispose des marques demeure
insuffisant pour lui permettre d'exercer
une tutelle stratégique au niveau
central sur l'apd et même si chacun
reconnaît que des efforts ont été
apportées notamment sur projet de loi
tendant à porter de nouveaux jeux pour
elle évoque également le cee qui
regrette que le projet de loi n'a pu
être l'occasion donnée d'un pilotage de
d'amour de la france
un portage politique fort et unique ce
que je vous l'avais dit monsieur le
ministre il ya plusieurs tutelles et
c'est vrai que c'est un vieux débat dans
cette
dans cette instance où la question d'un
ministre d'exercice sur la question de
la coopération et posez donc la question
est un peu quid d'un meilleur
fonctionnement vous l'avez dit vous avez
une réunion de calage mais aux dates de
stage on note c'est que ce projet de loi
rajoute des instances notamment le
conseil présidentiel
on pourrait s'interroger il rajoute le
conseil local pense que c'est une bonne
mesure pour le devenir conseiller en
l'espèce
et c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui entre l'oci
side le cost est ce que vous constatez
qu ils se réunissent pas assez ou trop
est ce que le conseil neutre à sion joue
bien son rôle e s communistes pas
vraiment pendant ce qu'on l'a agir sur
la sd au delà de vous même les autres
nice notamment ceux de bercy donc
comment on peut on corriger ces défauts
à ce stade parce que nous considérons
que le texte ne va pas assez loin
la deuxième question porte sur la taxe
sur les transactions financières c'est
un fait que nous avons déjà abordé à
l'occasion du projet de loi l'an dernier
puisque je rappelle que cette taxe la
taxe sur les transactions financières
est créée spécifiquement pour financer
l'aide publique au développement n'est
qu'aujourd'hui seulement un tiers un
tiers des 1 27 milliard qu'elle rapporte
un tiers va alimenter le fsd et donc le
projet de loi évoque une augmentation de
7 par 200 millions d'euros
donc ce qui nous emmènerait perd un peu
plus ce n'est pas suffisamment et qui
n'est pas d'automaticité dans la durée
donc donc monsieur ministre parce que
vous êtes faussurier favorables à un
accroissement significatif de la table
de la part de l'atp être consacrés à
cette boutique donc de 30 % à 40 5 ans
voire plus qui nous semblerait quelque
part entre divers revenir à deux autres
première de la taxe sur cette situation
financière troisièmement vous l'avez
tous salué je crois que on est tous
d'accord sur la question est là la
nouvelle commission indépendante
d'évaluation
c'est un aussi un vieux combat du
président cambon donc c'est important de
rappeler que je crois que chacun là
dessus est d'accord elle fera placé
auprès de la cour des comptes et son
secrétariat sera assuré par cette
dernière
concrètement comment vous vous engagez
vous son fonctionnement est ce que c'est
comme d'autres instances qui sont
arrachés rattachés
auprès de la cour des comptes lesquels
seraient tous voulaient mans même si
j'en doute à l'heure vous propose sur le
plus réduit possible et je crois que
vous avez quelques d'être intéressant
d'échanger avec vous le rôle des
parlementaires
la capacité droite virage aujourd'hui
effectivement le parlement peut demander
mais faut-il aller plus loin et sous
quelle forme sur sept sont là et puis
dernier élément qu'on ne pas être long
sur la vous l'avez évoqué au début c'est
une loi de programmation qui couvrent
jusqu'en 2025 et vous l'avez dit
vous-même
en données chiffrées je ne parle pas de
l'objectif
en données chiffrées nous avons sur la
star est en 2022 et donc on voit bien
que finalement 2023/2024 2025 n'y a
aucune données annuelles
alors bien sûr il ya une clause de
revoyure en 2022 mais je crois que pour
qu'elle soit totalement remonte allons
présenter ce texte là dans quelques
semaines maintenant dans les cycles je
pense qu'il serait important du projet
2000 23 24 et 25 il ya des données
chiffrées qui nous permettrait pour le
coup d'être vraiment dans une loi de
programmation
voilà monsieur liste mais quatre points
d'observation et d'amélioration du
projet doit à présent je connaisse merci
chers rapportait remercie rapide alors
je vais passer la parole au rapporteur
de la commission des finances qui nous
font l'amitié d'être en liaison avec
nous et tout d'abord le président jean
claude requier que je salue deux
rapporteurs spéciaux
la commission des finances chargé de la
depuis que développement et donc qu'on
vécu le place comme rapporteur spécial
pour ce texte c'est madame qui qui suis
qui a été désigné mais nous travaillons
de concert avec michel canevet alors
monsieur nice où les mots oui on fait ça
y est c'est arrivé et nous serions donc
là assorties de textes et avec messieurs
le canoë dans notre rapport du bouquet
l'arlésienne que le texte est maintenant
et donc finalisé ce sens très heureux de
le voir mais moi j'aurai qu'une question
laissé entendre à d'autres moments c'est
là la mission budgétaire que vous auriez
souhaité monsieur le ministre après 2007
et de comment dire il a si tu es mal
donc il ya une courbe
mais il ya un vrai qu'il ya plus de 6
rapp réduite de 2 alors pour maintenir
l'effort significatif est-ce qu'on peut
arriver au 07 ski on dépassera les 25
mai les skis faudrait savoir quelques
temps qu'elle saurait les sommes
nécessaires au respect la trajectoire à
sa charge la programmation est pas
toujours
qu'elle allait tomber ma question c'est
que la mission militaire vous auriez
vous souhaité après 2012 et de se le
dise merci jean claude michel canevet
merci monsieur le président merci
monsieur le ministre
sa collègue effectivement en complément
de ce qu'a dit le président qui peut
être quelques autres questions sur le
fonctionnalités pour le développement
comme l'évoqué racheter mal tout à
l'heure il importe de savoir comment
celui ci va être financier puisque le
double financement aujourd'hui dans
contexte que l'on connaît avec les
difficultés de transport aérien pose
aussi difficulté sur le financement du
fdf est donc comment peut-on arriver à
obtenir une garantie de financement de
ce fonds
autre question sur le transfert
d'expertisé france est-ce que ce
transfert qui est prévu par la loi
les étapes en une étape à la loi c'est
le traceur à des temps et puis ensuite
il est envisagé sinon on a bien compris
le transfert des 100 % à la f10 ne
faudrait-il pas pour des raisons de
souplesse envisagé approche indirecte
par le texte à l'afd si l'intention est
effectivement de disposer de deux
expertises france au sein du groupe
asd toujours sur sur la f10 d'un sujet
d'une part est ce qu'il ne faut pas
avoir un niveau de déconcentration des
décisions
je veux dire par là que est ce que
toutes les décisions de la ftq doivent
systématiquement remonter au conseil
d'administration ne faudrait-il pas
avoir un système qui soit je dirais plus
souple pour permettre une meilleure
efficience a fortiori dès lors qu'il y à
un consensus local autour des modalités
d'intervention et puis sur la question
des frais administratifs de la rti qu'il
est prévu dans le texte qui passe de 400
millions en 2020 437 millions entre les
22e ce qui correspond à une augmentation
de l'ordre de 10% à peu près est ce que
cela correspond à une réelle logique de
besoin parce que on est dans un contexte
où
il a demandé en particulier par les
services de l'état une certaine rigueur
est ce qu'il ne faut pas qu'il y ait
aussi une rigueur assez forte pour
laisser à des agences dépendant de
l'état on avait cru qu'ils sont
complémentaires monsieur précédentes je
souhaitais posée merci michel ruimy je
vous propose de répondre à porter puis
après on prendra les questions cribles
vous pouvez répondre collectivement
frère je peux répondre maintenant
d'autre que auxquelles je répondrai sans
doute plus tard pour vérifier des des
points ce qui est des questions qui sont
plus techniques que d'autres d'abord sur
la question de l'interrogation majeure
sur lequel on reviendra sûrement dans le
débat général sur ce qui est pilotable
ou pas pilotable programme a pas
programmables dans les dépenses puisque
l'aide publique au développement
les critères ne dépendent pas de nous
pour la clarification de l'affectation
des dépenses mais sont des normes ocde
comme vous le savez est à l'intérieur
évidemment de l'aide publique au
développement il ya des des vecteurs qui
sont intégrés à l'aide publique au
développement le plus spectaculaire que
je connaisse mais c'est comme ça
concerne les frais d'écolage des
étudiants chinois ça sade deux aspects
un peu bizarre d'abord le fait que si
c'est compris dans les aides publiques
au développement
ça veut dire donc que la chine est
toujours considérée comme un pays en
développement c'est le cas dans la
nomenclature générale la chine est
toujours considéré comme un pays en
développement et croyez bien que nos
collections de section public là mais
enfin ce point là peut-être pourra pas
pour éviter d'être au courant du mais
j'ai souvenir de d'avoir c'est en direct
face à face je mesure ce que je mesure
ce que je dis puisque tout ça j'ai eu
l'occasion une fois à shanghai sa vie
devant les tours là de d'être en
situation de dîner devant c'est tour
c'est un spectacle magnifique avec mon
collègue chinois et je lui dis on voit
quand même bien que vous êtes un pays en
développement quand on voit tout ça
c'est vraiment je compte vraiment c'est
un pays en développement voie de
développement qui est très particulier
mais il n'empêche que il n'empêche que
ils tiennent cette logique je fais une
petite parenthèse nez les lèvres le le
le
la part dans l'allée publique au
développement de l'écolage liés aux
étudiants chinois signifie deux choses 1
qui a
que la chine est toujours un pic
considérée comme un pays en
développement et 2 qu' il y à des
étudiants chinois qui viennent en nombre
en france et qui payent leur ai donc
avec avec des bourses et des de
l'accueil c'est peut-être une
contradiction que l'on peut souligner
mais c'est ça explique une partie de
cette interprétation donc est-ce que
l'on peut identifier de l'aide de
l'identité de lettres pilotable et
qu'elle la part de l'aide pilotable
globale que nous pouvions imaginer
j'avais les chiffres tout à l'heure mais
je ne les retrouve plus mais je vais
fouler les signaler en tout cas led led
pilotable direct à augmenter
sensiblement
on retrouve plus le papier vous devez
non non non j'ai peur de ne pas je sais
pas ce que j'en ai fait je vous ferai
passer les chiffres en tout cas les
jeunes les chiffres a service et voilà
dans ses peurs en fait on a on a pu
constater une augmentation significative
de la partie pilotable dans l'ensemble
de notre aide qui est significative
depuis plusieurs années je serai
vraiment heureux de retrouver ma note
qui permet de considérer que nous sommes
sur une voie positive y compris
d'ailleurs sur la partie à évider la
question de savoir si voilà l'objet
aujourd'hui c'est à un tiers du pilota
blaise à 140% en or en 2022
je pourrais faire le descriptif complet
lors de l'assaut de la séance plénière
mais c'est une vraie question de
l'appréciation de notre véritable aide
au développement sur les sujets qui sont
notre propre maîtrise sur les autres
remarque vous m'avez fait concernant
l'aide bilatérale
cette aide bilatérale ne cesse de
croître puisque nous sommes passés de 57
% en 2015 à 61% en 2019 en 2020 ça
devrait être près de 70%
j'avais toujours dit que l'aide
bilatérale devait se renforcer par
rapport à l'aide multilatérale et sur
les dons les publics français c'est 80 %
de dons 14% de près et cinq pour cent
d'appui au secteur privé et sur la fdc
vrai que la sdn part importante de près
mais les dons représentait au départ de
dire au moment où j'ai pris les affaires
en responsabilité 4% de l'activité de
l'afd maintenant ça représente 13% à une
progression très significative des dons
de la part de la ld voilà les chiffres
que je pouvais
sur lesquels je pouvais donner une
réponse aux rapporteurs souris en
sachant que sur la partie pilotable et
et non pilotable si votre interrogation
est de savoir si on peut avoir des
référentiels parce que je crois compris
ça dans vos propos pour nous permettre
de juger la part pilotable ena par
pilotable l'augmentation à l'intérieur
de chacun des critères
moi je suis prêt à prendre des
amendements sur le sujet si vous avez
les critères mais c'est pas c'est pas
facile à identifier parce que dans la
partie non pilotable des éléments qui
sont qui sont tout à fait tout à fait
variable je voulais sur la sd je vous ai
indiqué on peut se poser
je sais que certains peuvent se poser la
question de la relation prêts dont au
sein de l'afd puisque comme je vous ai
dit tout à l'heure la part des dons sur
dans l'aide publique
je française est de 81% mais l'essentiel
vient hors asd
mais nous avons souhaité que la fdn soit
aussi un outil pour développer les dons
puisque aujourd'hui je crois qu'en 2021
ses doigts de 874 278 millions d'euros
de dons de l'afd dont projet ou dons par
le biais des initiatives des ong
et il importe que cela se poursuive
parce que dans beaucoup de cas sur en
plus dans les cas de projets dans des
pays dans les 19 pays concernés mais
même dans les autres pays à revenu
intermédiaire dans beaucoup de cas il
faut articuler à la fois les dons et les
prêts faire faire des faire des dons les
braises s'organise généralement sur les
infrastructures les dons sont plutôt sur
du fonctionnement mais j'ai été amenée à
constater que on est amené à faire à la
fois l'un et l'autre et que l'afd
soutient les deux projets je pense à
l'exemple que je voulais vous donner
celle à l'institut pasteur à dakar qui
est soutenu par l'afd à la fois par une
combinaison de subventions donc de dont
deux millions deux millions sept et de
prêts pour financer la construction
d'unités de production qui permet de
doubler la capacité de production de
vaccins c'est des vaccins contre la
fièvre jaune sort bientôt les vaccins
contre la copie et la subvention permet
d'avoir les activités de surveillance
épidémiologique et la formation du
personnel de santé donc souvent envie de
faire les deux en même temps et c'est
l'arrêt l'intérêt de d'avoir un outil
unique pour pour agir en ce sens voilà
pour monsieur
vouvry en sachant je reconnais justement
vos interrogations sur la question de
programme ap non programmables deux
pilotes allemands pilotable encore
faut-il pouvoir trouver des idées les
bons critères pour tout cela sur sur la
question de monsieur tu es mal
concernant la tutelle moi je les ai sur
le pilotage
d'abord la tutelle elle est inscrite
dans la loi c'était pas le cas désormais
après c'est le si le texte est voté
l'afd orale il est écrit que l'est la et
v sous la tutelle de l'état
ce n'était pas le cas auparavant et donc
c'était essentiel de le mettre
deuxièmement sur le pilotage
je crois que le pilotage le conte le
conseil présidentiel
il a uniquement pour but de se réunir
une fois par an avec les ministres
concernés pour que les hommes et le
premier ministre pour que les
orientations soient soit donnée et pour
valider le fait que la politique de
développement est un élément central de
la police la politique étrangère et donc
ça se fait dans une instance sur la
politique étrangère il ya des conseils
des défenses qui définissent la
politique étrangère va sur cette partie
de la politique devient une fois par an
le président réunit les principaux
ministres pour dire voilà quelles sont
les orientations que nous retenons pour
la politique de développement donc je
sais pas je crois un encombrement
supplémentaires ses confrères une
impulsion qui est qui est donné et qui
est d'ailleurs un peu à l'origine de la
ddt l'accélération dont vous faisiez
état les uns et les autres de pour la
mise en oeuvre de ce texte deux mois sur
les autres outils le le sida a pour but
de mettre en oeuvre la politique de
développement une fois par an là aussi
mais avec tous les outils nécessaires et
la présence des acteurs directement
concernés et c'est votre humble
serviteur qui a pour vocation de mettre
en avant
alors c'est vrai qu'il y à un
rattachement je ne sais qu'ils me c
monsieur canévet qui voguait sacchi un
rattachement théorique à deux ministères
la réalité concrète fait que c'est
l'essentiel se fait au niveau du
ministère des affaires étrangères
personne ne le conteste donc j'essaye
d'assumer mes fonctions aussi deux
ministres du développement de fête et
l'intérêt de du site ces deux là aussi
de dire les enjeux et l'intérêt après de
la fonction c'est de la mettre en oeuvre
c'est ce que j'essaye de faire de
manière peut-être pas suffisamment
clarifier dans les responsabilités des
uns et des autres mais je vous rassure
ça n'entraîne aucune difficulté entre
bruno le maire et moi même sur sur ce
sujet je n'ai pas sur l'intervention du
président de la commission des finances
concernant la mise en oeuvre du 07 en
moi je suis interrogatif sur la validité
aujourd'hui d'écrire des chiffres parce
que je m'étonne que ce qu'elles sont
nées parrot est posée mais quand on met
un pourcentage 0 55 07
on ne peut pas mener pas tous les on ne
met pas sur la table l'ensemble des
facteurs puisqu'il ya aussi le volume de
financement auxquelles ces correspond et
comme vous le savez nous allons
atteindre en 2021 un pourcentage
supérieur à 0 55
puisque en 2021 nous allons être
normalement à 0,69 pour double raison
c'est d'une part parce que nous sommes
en crise que le pib baisse et donc
puisque le pib baisse pas le pourcentage
est plus facile à atteindre première
raison est deuxième raison parce que en
en 2021 nous allons régler la question
de la dette soudanaise qui est un acte
en soi de développement puisque nous
allons à part du moment où on règle le
problème de la dette soudanaise ça
permet aussi à ce pays de ceux de se
développer
c'est un acte de développement mais
évidemment ce serait c'est aussi
considérée comme une contribution de la
france au développement donc ça rentre
de la comptabilisation
mais je vais pas avoir l'outrecuidance
de vous dire venir en 2021
bien avant tout le monde on a réussi à
atteindre presque 0 70 07 % parce qu'en
2022 ça va baisser mais et donc je pense
qu'il serait opportun d'attendre la
sortie de crise pour essayer d'évaluer
les engagements financiers pour
atteindre 0,7
la grande nouveauté et c'est que nous
avons cette orientation d'aboutir à 0.7
en 2022 on peut imaginer des scénarii
mais on peut imaginer des scénarii
qu'une fois qu'on est à peu près
sûr d'être sortie de la crise sanitaire
et économique dans laquelle nous sommes
avec un pib qui est entrée en récession
mais malgré le pays bas en récession
j'ai obtenu que l'on maintienne les
engagements financiers de progression de
nos dépenses de développement ce qui
n'est pas qu'à tous les pays je vous
fais remarquer que le royaume uni a
décidé de prendre le fait qu'ils les
avaient dépassé les 0 7% parce qu'il y
avait une baisse du pib donc ils ont
diminué les les aides au développement à
à prata sur la sur la ttf je pense que
on peut écouter avec attention les
propositions
le projet de loi je suis de ces deux
interventions ne s'était mal et et
monsieur cadrede le projet de loi
prévoit 100 millions d'euros de plus de
la part de la de la ttf
moi je suis ouvert pour aller plus loin
mais
il faut surtout pas toucher ni autonomie
à l'assiette parce qu'à ce moment là ça
pose des problèmes mais sur la
réaffectation au développement d'une
partie de la recette qu'il ne revient
pas directement au développement alors p
initialement c'était prévu pour ça je
suis ouvert à tous vos encouragements et
à toutes vos propositions parce que sur
le fond je suis je suis en phase
voilà je crois que j'ai dit ce que je
voulais dire alors que la commission
d'évaluation
monsieur tu es mal et monsieur kone
mettent aussi moi je suis très ouvert à
vos propositions et d'une certaine
manière plus globalement c'est ce que
j'ai dit à l'assemblée nationale je
pense que ce texte de loi d'oise
c'est un texte majeur pour la présence
de la france dans le monde et doit
essayer de troupes prendre en
considération toutes les contributions
qui peuvent être pertinentes dans cette
affaire il y en a eu de différents bords
qui ont été effectuées à l'assemblée
nationale dans la commission j'ai ouvert
à ce que vous pourrez dire le principe
de fond mais c'est le vôtre c'est
l'indépendance le deuxième principe de
fond c'est que cette commission rende
compte au parlement
le troisième principe de fond c'est que
cette commission puisse être saisi aussi
par les parlementaires
à partir de là je suis ouvert à ce que à
ce que les uns et les autres peuvent
peuvent dire l'autre principe qui a été
hâtée que c'est que ce ça dépendra de la
cour dès que ce sera attaché là pour des
causes qui me paraît un gage
d'indépendance aussi mais au delà parce
qu'il faut qu'elle soit efficace que
c'est pas c'est pas une commission je le
redis qui vérifie la bonne justesse des
comptes
ces commissions qui vérifie si la
politique menée juste
c'est pas du tout la même chose et c'est
sans doute pas du tout le même profil de
demande de la commission après savoir
s'il faut mettre des parlementaires ou
non vous serez amené à regarder
est ce que c'est un critère
d'indépendance ou pas moi j'étais plutôt
moi j'étais plutôt réservé à l'assemblée
lorsque cette question a été posée
si vous voulez que ce soit indépendant
c'est vraiment indépendant si c'est mans
il ya des parlementaires dans la
commission c'est différent d'après vous
mais je suis comme je suis pas bloqué je
perds je pense avec alors voilà je vous
crois que j'ai dit les sens et c'est un
point très c'est un point très important
pour nous parce que partout où il ya des
parlementaires et il ya de nombreux
organismes que ce soit là la cntr que ce
soit
le comité national d'éthique ce soit la
cnil et sert à la présence de
parlementaires ne rompt pas lien
d'objectivité de ses biens au contraire
je veux dire j'ai je peux vous dire que
ayant travaillé avec avec hervé berline
qui était rapporteur du projet devant
l'assemblée
on est plutôt d'accord sur cette ligne y
compris en prévision de deux
la cmp on ne demande pas que ce soit les
parlementaires qui veut cornac
l'ensemble mais il nous semble que la
présence de deux sénateurs de débuter
par exemple est justement un gage
d'indépendance car la nomination
d'experts indépendants enfin on le voit
sur l'autre sujet en matière d'éthique
en matière sanitaire
on voit tous les combats qui se mène
autour de ce concept je pense que les
parlementaires qui vienne siéger dans
ces organismes commençaient du reste par
l'afd fallait parlementaire que de
différentes et et de différentes
couleurs politiques ont siégé à l'afd
ont toujours tenu leur rôle face est
important que vous n'y soyez déjà pas
totalement hostile ministre d'accord
d'un élément important je pense au net
mais ça se discute
moi j'ai le président de la cour des
comptes que j'ai vus en tête-à-tête
longuement la semaine hier il ya 10
jours a dit que lui-même il était très
favorable qui trouvait que c'était assez
légitime que le parlement dont la
mission est de contrôler quand même
l'action du gouvernement
puis siéger dans un organisme qui vise à
évaluer si les opérations sont positives
ou pas bien alors maintenant on va
passer aux aux questions cribles à
raison d'une minute et d'une question
est donc c'est jacques le nay qui
démarre et voilà la vérité si vous
voulez à la totalité ou et parce que
sans ça ça fait dix ans oui de
simplement deux observations plus que
des questions
ce mini ce rôle d ambassadeur et est
renforcée par le projet de loi à travers
la réunion annuelle du conseil local de
développement
cette relocalisation d'une partie de la
gouvernance de notre aide publique au
développement doit être salué cependant
les retours et conclusions de ces
conseils locaux doivent être examinées
plus en contre comment notre réseau
développement va-t-il se restructurer
autour de cette nouveauté à l'échelle
locale pour peser bien sûr sur les choix
des projets mais également en effectuer
le suivi c'est important et le modèle
des taux développement multilatéral
proposée par la france peut-il
concurrencer les aides chinoises vous en
avez parlé tout à l'heure
notamment sur le continent africain les
chinois sont partout alors qu'une aide
chinois c'est connu et reconnu
jusqu à l'international les aides
françaises passe trop souvent inaperçue
notamment du grand public n'y at il pas
un déficit de communication autour des
projets financés par la france déficit à
palier afin de participer au rayonnement
de notre pays
merci alors marié arlette carlotti
oui merci monsieur le président monsieur
le ministre oui en effet ce texte était
très attendu et je trouve qu'il ya des
avancées certaines puisque ça nous a été
dit par les gens que nous auditionnons
que ce soit des associations que ce
soient les personnalités comme le droit
d'initiative des associations les biens
mal acquis ou il reste encore des
dispositions à mettre en oeuvre pour que
ce soit applicable concrètement le
devoir de vigilance bon jeu j'ai deux
questions moi même si je me rapproche de
ce qui a été dit tout à l'heure par a
cité mal et l'autre rapporte
co-rapporteur c'est sur la trajectoire
financière c'est vrai que ça aurait
quand même nécessité connaissent
jusqu'en 2025 malgré la cause de
revoyure mais ça a été déjà dit moi mes
questions se posent l'une sur ce que je
considère comme une actuellement une
dispersion des fonds aujourd'hui la
priorité affichée et j'en suis ravi
c'est de mettre l'accent sur les 19 pays
prioritaires c'est vraiment pas le cas
donc il va falloir redresser
effectivement le tir puisque quand on
regarde aujourd'hui c'est que 15 % de
l'aide publique au développement qu'il
va vers les pays prioritaires donc ça
veut dire monsieur le ministre qui va
absolument qui va falloir que vous
redresser sacrément le tire d'autant que
si on fait des projections maintenant
d'ici la fin de l'année 2021 il
semblerait que ce soit à peine 5% que
nous atteignons donc comment vous allez
redresser le tir et notamment avec la
vision particulière de mettre l'accent
sur l'afrique et sur le g5 sahel parce
qu'on sait très bien que pour restaurer
la paix il faudra aussi lutter contre la
misère
comment vous allez redressé à ce point
le tir quel outil parce que vous avez
des affiches et des priorités qui me
semble fondamental mais comment vous
allez pouvoir les mettre réellement en
oeuvre et vous avez vraiment besoin de
les mettre en oeuvre pour que on
récupère la situation d'ici 2021
ma deuxième question c'est le pilotage
il ya des points positifs dans ce texte
vous conforter le cndh ci qui a été
créée en 2014
et c'est bien voilà vous créez les
conseils locaux de développement je
crois que tout le monde s'accorde à dire
qu'on est content que nous ambassadeurs
reprennent du poids dans les territoires
dans les pays et en plus ça permettra
aux petits projets très précis proche
des populations de se réaliser mieux
donc ça c'est bien mais pour le reste
monsieur le ministre je suis pas tout à
fait d'accord avec vous en tout cas en
ce qui me concerne
vous avez dit tout à l'heure qui la
chaîne de décision a été clarifiée moi
je la trouve extrêmement complexe dans
ce texte je la trouve peu lisible je
comprends pas comme va quitter mal même
si vous avez commencé à lui répondre à
quoi sert le conseil autour du président
de la république vous avez dit une fois
par an il va recadrer ou revalider la
politique d'orientation fall autre
orientation
je comprends pas si ce n'est pour
construire un système extrêmement
pyramidale et donc j'ai envie le
ministre du développement vous assumer
la fonction mais je trouve encadré aussi
dans ce texte extrêmement encadré ma
question c'est alors qu'ils commandent
au bout du bout
merci cette langue questions et de la
brièveté de la réponse richard yong sais
pas je fais dans ma liste mais merci
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre
dans vos propos vous avez insisté sur un
aspect qui est un aspect essentiel et
c'est celui des enjeux relatifs à
l'éducation et que une stratégie de
développement ne pouvait aller pour être
efficace que de pair avec une stratégie
donc d'éducation et c'est un jeu
important plus particulièrement pour les
19 pays
donc qu'ils seront plus particulièrement
centré pour être bénéficiaire de cette
aide au développement
moi je voudrais vous interrogez monsieur
le ministre par rapport à la même
période nécessité selon moi et
certainement d'un certain nombre de nos
collègues de mettre en cohérence
cette stratégie est cette volonté avec
la promotion de la défense de la
francophonie
parce que c'est aussi un élément est un
enjeu important parce qu'au travers de
la langue française c'est aussi j'allais
dire une certaine idée certaines valeurs
que nous promouvrons et que nous
défendons et donc est ce que monsieur le
ministre il y aura un engagement fort
pour essayer donc de favoriser
l'apprentissage du français est une
forme de discrimination positive donc
pour les actions qui seront menées en
matière d'éducation pour que celle ci
puisse concerner donc l'apprentissage du
français et ensuite deuxième de deuxième
question qui est lié par rapport à la
stratégie
dead au développement par les pays qui
sont les pays francophones
pourront-ils aussi bénéficier d'une
d'une forme de dead spécifique au regard
de lienne historique que nous avons avec
avec ces pays là est-ce que ça rentre
dans ja dire les purs de de la stratégie
que vous souhaitez voir mises en place à
la matière merci merci richard yong
[Musique]
merci merci président je garde les
remarques générales et l'appréciation
générale pour le le débat qui aura lieu
à la fois en commission et ensuite en
séance 3-3 roma vous n'avez pas évoquer
expertise france dans votre dans votre
speech liminaire c'est une excellente
chose qu'on rapproche expertise france
et l aft la question que je me suis
posée c'est pourquoi est ce que c'est
une mécanique aussi compliquée que celle
qui est mise en place avec la création
d'une société
par action limitée dont la sd ensuite
prendra une part facettes une ça me
semble une une sorte d'usiné à gaz bien
compliquée si on me demande mais on me
le demande pas j'aurais dit intégrons
expertise france directement dans la f10
a fait une des directions générales de
la vie des enfants donc j'ai une
question est l'interrogation là dessus
deuxièmement un des points qui m'a qui
nous a semblé un peu faible
c'est le rôle des collectivités
d'outre-mer les collectivités
d'outre-mer peuvent jouer un rôle
important dans les actions de
développement elles ont d'ailleurs cette
cette fonction la loi les chimie et
d'autre je pense qu'il faudra que dans
la discussion sans doute on rajoute
quelques références à leur rôle et à
leur financement et au fait que l'afd
finance les collectivités d'outre-mer
c'est le cas depuis depuis la libération
enfin sur la commission d'évaluation je
parlerai pas sur les de la place des
parlementaires ça sera un débat
intéressant
je pense par contre que ça serait une
bonne chose qu'il y ait des
représentants un de représentants des
pays qui reçoivent l'aide c'est à dire
qu'ils peuvent juger de ce qui est fait
c'est peut-être compliqué du point de
vue du droit public je ne sais pas mais
je crois que c'est utile
fondée par exemple le président de la
cour des comptes du sénégal ou de la
cour des comptes de la côte d'ivoire qui
nous donne un avis dans cette commission
d'évaluation merci bien
merci richard olivier cadic si monsieur
le président monsieur le ministre j'ai
particulièrement apprécié votre remarque
sur la chine pays doit d'être
développement en observant les
gratte-ciel à shanghai
l'ambassadeur du japon se tenait en
france se tenait ce matin très
exactement à votre place et lui il
observait que la chine était un pays en
voie de développement militaire en mer
de chine méridionale
un des objectifs du projet de loi est de
promouvoir la gouvernance démocratique
économique et financière je cite votre
texte la gouvernance démocratique et
l'état de droit sont des conditions
essentielles de l'efficacité de l'aide
au développement
il est sain de le rappeler et sommes
nombreux à soutenir dans cette démarche
d'autres pays n'ont pas la même démarche
et nous font concurrence
il rejette la gouvernance démocratique
au prétexte que le développement passent
avant les droits humains
comment prévoyez-vous que des acteurs
économiques des entreprises venant de
pays qui ne partagent pas notre vision
de l'état de droit et des droits humains
ne puisse gagner des marchés financés
par l'aide publique au développement de
la france
vous avez cité l'exemple du xinjiang
pouvons-nous envisager de faire une
liste noire de pays qui ne respectent
pas les droits humains afin que les
entreprises de ces pays soit exclu
automatiquement des marchés qui ne
bénéficient de l'afd
ça va éclaircir le paysage là
joëlle garriaud-maylam si beaucoup trois
points rapides monsieur mini changerait
vraiment vous remercier pour un sujet en
particulier qui est celui de
l'intégration des femmes dans le
développement
je suis sénatrice depuis 2004 membre de
cette commission depuis 2004 pendant des
années j'ai plaidé pour qu'enfin il y
léchage envers les femmes dans tous les
rapports sur le développement qui était
présentée pendant des années les femmes
n'étaient même pas mentionné donc
vraiment je vous remercie parce qu'il
faut aller de l'avant sur ce sujet et
peut-être que si vous pouviez nous en
dire un petit peu plus sur ce fléchage
vous en serez très reconnaissante parce
que ce sont les premiers acteurs et les
premiers moteurs du développement on le
voit bien ce sont elles qui rembourse
toujours les petits prêts qu'on peut
leur accorder le taux de différence
entre les hommes et les femmes sur ces
micro crédit est quand même extrêmement
instructif deuxième point
vous avez parlé de ses conseils de
développement locaux c'est aussi une
excellente initiative que d'inviter
d'autres partenaires d'autres états je
voudrais vous demander je pense que
c'est prévu mais je voudrais m'en n'est
sûr et c'est pour cela que je vous le
dis il serait très important me semble
utile qu'ils soient associés les
représentants élus des français des
tranchées nous avons beaucoup de
français qui sont souvent établis depuis
très longtemps dans ces pays qui font
vraiment partie du pays qui le
connaissent parfaitement qu'il a encore
pendant des années avaient été exclues
de prêt de lâcher des ou de proparco
parce qu'ils étaient français
alors qu'ils ont tellement apporté donc
ça me paraît un point très important
troisièmement la francophonie ça a été
abordée tout à l'heure mais je voudrais
rajouter un aspect dont j'ai eu
l'occasion déjà de vous parler dans des
commissions successives ces
l'audiovisuel extérieur qu'il ne faut
pas oublier parce qu'il est extrêmement
important pour le développement pour le
développement de l'information sanitaire
par exemple mais aussi pour l'éducation
et l'enseignement
et pas seulement du france merci si joël
enfin en visio andré guiol c'est à
l'unisson micro faille est toujours
président non je ministre vous avez
précisé monsieur le ministre il existe
des critères visant à mesurer des
résultats de nos actions de solidarité
envers les pays que nous soutenons dans
les domaines aussi importants que
l'éducation et la protection de
l'environnement à questionner de
l'existante idée indicateur qui mesure
la manière de la france est perçue par
les populations de tous ces pays et je
pense avec tristesse ce que j'ai
ressenti quand j'ai pu voir des
manifestations contre la france dans de
tristes épisodes de les caricatures et
guillaume est justement la solidarité
que ce soit et supplée d'autres pays
merci monsieur le ministre vous pouvez
maintenant répondre à nos collègues
parfois un peu dans le désordre mais oui
c'est pas grave
sur la question du pilotage
madame carlotti je vois pas en quoi
c'est compliqué j'entends bien que
j'entends cela se répéter président de
la république est dans son rôle de
réunir une fois par an ça se faisait pas
auparavant mais je considère que c'est
même très normal de ça se fasse les
quelques ministres qui sont directement
concernés pour dire voilà mes
orientations il là il a fait au mois de
décembre ça a permis de débloquer
beaucoup de choses c'est pas un
organisme d'action c'est un organisme de
c'est un lieu de d'orientation
stratégique
ensuite vous avez le site qui est le
lieu de la mise en oeuvre de l'ensemble
des politiques de développement et mal
je suis chargé de l'exécution
ça paraît simple et à côté de cela vous
avez le cnds si le ciel de des
collectivités territoriales cncd qui
permettent de donner conseils etc mais
que compellent je participe je vais
danser leurs séances pour pour écouter
et puis l'opéra l'opération très
concrètes au niveau de chacun des pays
concernés cdpi et géographie vous priez
prioritaire que j'ai vos pieds je
rajoute en termes de gouvernance que il
y a
que l'afd désormais et est tenu de faire
un contrat d'objectifs et de moyens et
dans ce contrat d'objectifs voyage je
fixe des cibles à l'afd auquel elle doit
répondre et je discute avec les vergers
deux outils d'action l'afd d'une part et
le ti budgétaire d'autre part qui est à
la fois le 117 209 plus le fsd d'une
certaine manière qui sont les outils
d'action et à l'afd je pose des cibles
je les ai pas l'âme je pourrais
voulez-vous les évoqué en séance
publique mardi
oui et qui équipe qui permettent pour
moi de vérifier si la fd remplit bien
son rôle globalement je reviens je suis
un peu plus circonspect sur heureuse que
vous aime je canévet tout à l'heure
c'est d'avoir une gestion décentralisée
de l'afd
pour l'instant je trouve que c'est
prématuré pour des raisons que ce qu'on
veut on comprend très bien
et donc je trouve qu'il faut mettre en
place d'abord les les outils locaux et
je vais y revenir parce que je suis le
même interrogé sur ce point mais
l'essentiel c'est que dans le contrat
d'objectifs et de moyens que que je vais
transmettre au sénat puisque je souhaite
que ces deux contrats d'objectifs et de
moyens ces contrats swaps soit vue par
les deux assemblées de contraste de la
sd contrat de l'afd avec l'eau qui dort
c'est donc avec une liste de tutelle
voilà et et le ministre de l'économie et
des finances mais voilà les objectifs
que l'on donné et je discute avec le
directeur général de l'afd des du
ciblage et de ses 48 je crois de mémoire
48 cible que là était de remplir dans
son contrat d'objectifs et de moyens
dans laquelle la question des femmes
dans la gestion de l'éducation des
filles pour reprendre ce que disent et
joël de tout à l'heure donc ça c'est un
point très important
moi je vois pas de souci majeur sur le
jeu tant que c'est plutôt de la mise en
clarté de la chaîne de décision à tous
égards
je pense plutôt l'avis contraire de ce
que vous évoquez mais ça nous incite à
faire attention
je pense que monsieur le ministre si je
m'en tiens nombreux sujets qu'on a
évoqué sur 6 sur ce point la d2 tous ces
conseils
le tout c'est que ça ne ralentissent pas
les opérations s'ils voulaient parce
qu'il ya toujours des comités et des
conseils dont la vie doit être
sollicitée avant que ça démarre ce qui
fait que quand par exemple on va prendre
des choses qui ne vise pas
l'administration française ne vous allez
au au fonds européen de développement
un euro qui a été décidé cet après midi
arrive dans quatre ans et demi ou cinq
ans dans le village en question parce
qu'il ya toute une série absolument
invraisemblable de consultation
d'échelon de signature etc
c'est ça le sujet c'est moi
personnellement ce sont des gens
extrêmement compétents
beaucoup sont là à titre bénévole fonda
un très bon train mais que ce soit pas
at-elle empilement toutes choses égales
par ailleurs inspirons nous de la
situation sanitaire pour en tirer des
leçons sur le reste des administrations
je rebondis sommes dans une conversation
si l'aïe il ya vraiment trois sujets sur
l'intervention j'ai souhaité renforcer
l'aide humanitaire et l'intervention
situation de crise on ne l'a pas évoquée
on va aboutir à normalement 2022 à 500
millions d'euros
je dis ça de mémoire mais je crois que
c'est ça de mobilisation financière
immédiate par là c'est le centre de
crise qui le fait il ne fait pas
directement il le fait lui aussi avec
des acteurs mais cet argent là il est
disponible tout de suite et il peut le
faire avec une ong qui par ailleurs sera
éligible à la fdea après ce sera
d'autres sujets mais il le fait il met
immédiatement donc il faut qu on
vraiment qu'on garde cette idée là c'est
tout à fait indispensable quand on dit
par exemple là on va mettre 50 millions
d'euros pour la partie syrienne
je pense à ça parce que c'est
intéressant pour moi là sur le nord
ouest syrien bon ah ça y est c'est
immédiat le centre de crise du quai
d'orsay sans s'en occuper et diligente
des choses sur les questions de
développement
c'est obligatoirement plus long et après
julien rey sur la partie intermédiaire
parce que
quand on veut faire l'institut pasteur
de dakar le bâtiment nouveau dans le
débat que j'évoquais tout à l'heure ça
suppose un certain temps il faut
identifier les acteurs ou quand on fait
le dr de dakar pour rester au sénégal ce
qu'était une action de développement
c'est une infrastructure va ça prend du
temps parce qu'il faut respecter des
normes des études c'est généralement un
peu long en med et donc je souhaite
qu'on fasse de l'accélération des
processus mais inévitablement ça ne peut
pas se faire dans la dans la réaction
yves de la réaction du du moment mais il
faut accélérer les procédures et les
procédures pour que un projet initié
n'attendent pas de 4 ans ou cinq ans
avant de se mettre en oeuvre c'est vrai
pour la et vidé mais c'est vrai pour les
aussi les différents fonds auxquels vous
faites référence y compris au niveau
européen
et puis il ya le sujet central pour moi
là maintenant c'est la phase
intermédiaire qu'on appelle phase de
stabilisation
il faut que ce soit les acteurs du
développement beaucoup plus réactif sur
la phase intermédiaire la phase de
stabilisation c'est généralement après
des crises donc c'est c'est pas tous les
pays en développement ces pays où il ya
eu des crises voire des ponts des
conflits voire des guerres civiles voire
des affrontements et c est là je trouve
qu'on n'est pas assez bon et nous avons
donc décidé de mettre en place dans ces
pays là aussi un outil d'accélération
pour que l'on soit vous rendez vous est
il assez pagnon pour la france et pour
l'ensemble des acteurs on peut pas avoir
le temps pour ça il faut il faut le
faire de la réaction immédiate quand
vous avez l'aide humanitaire c'est
l'alimentation le service de santé
immédiate c'est et puis dans la
stabilisation pas vous avez l'école
immédiatement enfin presque
immédiatement il faut la reconstruire un
peu un petit peu de temps mais il faut
il faut avoir un une accélération
possible dans cette dans cette dimension
qui est tout à fait essentiel ce qui
m'amène aussi
trajectoire je crois que j'ai répondu
avec les incertitudes mes mains on a
fait une loi de programmation a
posteriori mais elle al'avantage d'avoir
permis une mobilisation progressive des
financements parce que je sais que je
vais pas vous faire un inventaire des
progressions de chiffre
enfin c'est quand même pas si mal quoi
depuis 2010 est revenir sur le passé
mais quand on est passé de 0 38
on va être en état 0,44 année dernière
on va être à 0,50 plus que ça cette
année
ça se compte en milliards d'euros
supplémentaires donc cesser de du
palpable identifiable je pense que
l'ensemble de ces acteurs du
développement le reconnaissent et
et sûre sur les puisque je parlais de
milliards dans les pays les moins
avancés
nous concernant les 19 pays on est à 1 1
milliard de plus en 2010 9 en trois ans
que au début un milliard d'euros de plus
disponible en dons alors c'est vrai que
lorsque je reviens c'est une observation
je sais de qui tout à l'heure lorsqu'on
fait la comparaison au sein de
l'ensemble de l'aide publique au
développement on a des pourcentages qui
sont effectivement insatisfaisant dans
l'état des choses même s'ils sont en
progression mais vous comptez dans tout
cela
les collages des étudiants chinois va
compter dans tout ça d'autres d'autres
dimensions
c'est la turquie qui était en tête en
2010 neuf provinces et de tous les pays
où elle était quand même assez mais il y
avait des raisons à ça oui c'est que par
par exemple les fonds qui elles
permettent de de soutenir les réfugiés
qui sont en turquie qui se rappellent
des fonds frites ça ne s'invente pas et
vérité ça rentre là dedans quand il donc
on peut il faut vraiment avoir une bonne
clarifications sur les sur les chiffres
qu'est ce qui est de la paix des mets
servis à l'intervention de du rapporteur
tout à leur caisse qui est directement
pilotable par new hope et risqués ce qui
aide des éléments qui ne sont pas
contrôlés directement par par le
ministère des affaires étrangères où le
ministère du développement comme vous
vous le voulez et qui contribue à faire
qu'il ya des évolutions de pourcentage
différentes mais notre progression dans
tous ces domaines là est assez
spectaculaire et je crois vous l'avoir
des mais je leur dirai éventuellement en
séance publique sur la francophonie
monsieur folio c'est tout à fait
essentiel c'est dans le texte du
du projet de loi en particulier du dans
le contrat de partenariat de partenariat
il est indiqué l'essonne l'importance de
la francophonie la priorité à la
francophonie et nous pouvons constater
par ailleurs que sur les 19 pays
priorité à la grande majorité sont
francophones donc sur la partie
programme de l'eau pme partenariat pour
l'éducation c'est les fonds qui sont
affectés dans les pays francophones pour
le développement de l'éducation sont des
fonds qui indirectement sont aussi
affectés au développement de la
francophonie
il y aura c'est essentiel de se battre
pour la langue française
c'est un élément d' influence
considérable et c'est aussi un outil
dans dans l'enseignement il faut
continuer à se battre dans ses dents
dans cette direction il y aura un sommet
de la francophonie normalement cette
année à ceux se réunit tous les trois
ans en tunisie
si si du moins la situation sanitaire et
politique qui permette de le tenir dans
les bonnes conditions
moi je dis un point monsieur le net qui
ne préoccupe
il a fait des observations des constats
peu plus que des plus sûrs des questions
à deux points qui me préoccupe donc dans
ce qu'il a dit 3 parce que c'était
repris après est une des conséquences
pour moi dollar et futurs l'orientation
qui est prise dans le cas de ces lois
développement c'est de faire en sorte
que la filière développement au quai
d'orsay la filière professionnelle soit
revalorisé soient mieux prises en compte
et soient considérés comme parler les
agents du quai d'orsay comme une filière
d'avenir fier de carrière et non pas une
filière de seconde zone
doux
je suis satisfait que le personnes que
j'ai nommé comme directeur général de la
mondialisation soit un ambassadeur titre
et qui est par ailleurs avant été
ambassadeur au brésil parce que ça
manque que cette continuité arrière n
existe aussi par mais c est la verse
aussi qui compte six quand on va à la
direction de la mondialisation ont fait
carrière diplomatique après y'a pas de
ça donne une filière d'homme parce
qu'essentiel et parce que déterminante
ce qui veut dire aussi que dans les
postes on renforce la formation déco cac
qui ont aussi cette responsabilité se
considère comme une filière noble parce
que sinon on peut être amené à
sous-valorisées l'action développement
de notre pays il faut au contraire le
valoriser et faire en sorte que ce soit
conçu comme un élément de la diplomatie
française je le redis un élément de la
politique étrangère n'était pas le cas
avant ça n'a jamais été dire que la
politique du logement c'est un élément
de la politique étrangère par avant
c'était un truc à part
alors ça ça a peut-être quelques
inconvénients
ça veut dire si c'est un élément de la
politique étrangère c'est que ça veut
dire c'est diriger mais oui et sa
tournée dans une bataille d'influencé
permanente puisque en plus on avait eu
le nez m'a interrogé sur la concurrence
et sur la visibilité
oui et je pense qu'on est trop timide
dans la visibilité
ouais comme quand même je crois que j'ai
pu les chiffres en tête là mais je
voulais je voulais dire est au moment du
débat y compris sur la question des
vaccins
c'est pas parce qu'on met
[Musique]
quelques milliers de vaccins sur un
tarmac en afrique qu'on a réglé la
question vaccinale africaine la question
vaccinale africaine et se réglera par
l'initiative kovacs dont je vous ai déjà
parlé qui permettra de mobiliser 2
milliards de doses à la fin de cette
année et qui se permettra d'être
utilisés par le système qui est mise en
place et gavin qui permettent de
diffuser les vaccins dans le pays
concernant suffit pas des vaccins
arrivent qu'ils soient ensuite de yahia
la question français sur lesquelles je
reviendrai pas il est indispensable de
considérer que l'immunité sera globale
ou ne sera pas on dira on commence à se
dire on va voir limitée national très
bien mais bon il suffit pas d'avoir une
idée nationale il faudra hausser leurs
limites et globale et donc c'est pas
parce qu il y assure le tarmac de dakar
dès l'été vaccin si la femme ou des
vaccins spoutnik que on a réglé la
question vaccinale
j'appelle sable deux opérations de
propagande mais non c'est pas faire et
donc on donne l'illusion que dans ces
pays ça va être le vaccin foot nico pour
lequel j'ai beaucoup de respect parce
que c'est la fin pour lequel j'ai
beaucoup de respect qui va arriver là
qu'ils ont séparé il ya dix mille doses
de vaccin as poneys aussi la femme dans
tel pays mais il va y avoir il a
commencé à y avoir d'ailleurs déjà
puisqu'il ya soixante-cinq pays qui ont
été dans 100 pays qui ont déjà bénéficié
de kovacs qui va cette progression très
significative et là on aura eu les
échantillons c'est une politique des
champignons mais c'est comme ça que
certains moments mènent leur politique
d' influence c'est pas notre métier
c'est pas notre manière de faire mais
sans doute avons-nous le défaut ne pas
le faire savoir suffisamment y compris
dans des actes de communication par
exemple des vaccins blanc pourrait
prendre d'autres exemples
qui affiche notre présence et je pense
qu'on a un problème de lisibilité
globale y compris européens y compris
européens sur l'ensemble de l'aide au
développement sur lequel il voyageait
beaucoup plus que ce que nous faisons
aujourd'hui expertise france monsieur
yang parce que parce que c'est
indispensable que nous ayons globalement
une offre quand il ya une demande d'un
pays qui soit à la fois une offre qui
permet d'avoir une offre de prêt une
oeuvre de dons et une expertise
c'est ce que font les autres acteurs
d'en parler japonais tout à l'heure où
il faut qu'on arrive dans notre bagage
avec l'ensemble mais il faut en même
temps d'où le fait que re expertises
vont se rejoindre le paquet asd
mais ce n'est pas une filiale de l'afd
comme peut l'être au parcours qui est un
organe spécifique qui lui travaille avec
les entreprises privées de privé à privé
parce que
nous voulons aussi que expertise france
gardent une certaine forme d'autonomie
pour passer des commandes expertise
france de manière séparée mais que ça
reste dans le dans le lent semble de
l'afd pour être en situation de répondre
très rapidement à des à des demandes qui
sont formulés ou d identification de
projets qui peuvent être effectués en
apportant la garantie technique
nécessaire c'est ce que nous ont déjà
mais il faut le faire mieux plus
efficace ion avec eux expertise france
et donc le processus qui est proposé
c'est de permettre on ne fait pas de
finalisation on fait on a un dispositif
qui permet d'autre qui gardait qui
permet de l'autonomie d'explosifs france
dans le champ d'action de de l'afd ce
qui permettra aussi de passer des
commandes directes expertise france en
savoir automatiquement passage à le
passage parle par l'afd
je rajoute que il a été décidé de
doubler le nombre d'experts nous avons
aujourd'hui 140 experts techniques
internationaux et nous allons doubler le
nombre d'experts pour être en situation
de pouvoir répondre à une demande
immédiate qui ensuite entraînera la
mobilisation des expertises france 2 de
l'afd sur tel ou tel projet et c'est une
bonne manière de répondre à la
pénétration d'autres acteurs seront pas
réglés sur le territoire africain sur le
monsieur k dick sur l'état de droit
il ya dans le texte un dispositif qui
permet de l'identifier le l'exigence de
vigilance de des entreprises et de leurs
filiales à l'égard de d'acteurs qui ne
respecteraient pas les principes
fondamentaux des droits humains je pense
qu'on l'a fait pour le pour le signe en
on peut le faire aussi pour d'autres
pour d'autres pays donc je pense que
cette conditionnalité là est tout à fait
pris en compte par des orientations que
nous initions sur la politique de
développement et en particulier pour
éviter que des entreprises qui ne
respectent pas ces fondamentaux puissent
bénéficier éventuellement de prêts que
nous serions amenés à faire à d'autres
pays là comme je suis en audition
publique je ne dis pas plus mais c'est
cette ce point là est très très
important et de la vigilance à cet égard
est essentiel est certaine manière le
fait qu'il irait maintenant un comité
ad-hoc par site
autour novateur permettra aussi d'être
vigilant cette question puisque autour
des îles dira aussi non seulement le
responsable de la évident et le co 4
mais aussi le responsable des services
économiques qui siège autour de cette
instance sur
joël sur vos observations concernant les
femmes je crois que c'est en plus dans
le texte c'est pas dans le texte semble
bien qu'on avait aux aidants mais seront
amis on a insisté sur le cette prise en
considération et les enfants aussi fait
l'objet d'assez d'un d'une discussion
particulièrement significative sur les
conseillers des français et étrangers
ils sont prévus dans le conseil local de
développement
je voulais avoir le texte les cdc de
laval
oui j'ai pas compris exactement la
question de subingen parce que j'étais
dessinateur violent géré andré est ce
que vous pouvez re préciser votre
question au ministre oui c'est jeu suite
à la perception que je vois de notre
pays lorsqu'il ya le problème des
caricatures et je met en parallèle
actions que 20 de la france en terme de
solidarité
est-ce que nous avons une critères qui
mesure
le taux de satisfaction aux mondiaux
comme ça des populations leur adhésion à
notre action est ce qu'ils le savent au
niveau de la population
est-ce qu'ils le perçoivent est ce que
la france est justement votre housse est
évidemment merci en terme d'image mais
ça c'est dasa dépasse largement la
question du développement en termes
d'image on a un combat permanent à mener
face à des destructeurs d'image qui
utilisent l'effet news ou comme c'est
pas les faits c'est pour automatiquement
des faits news mais s'ils utilisent les
réseaux sociaux pour nous détruire
il ya des acteurs très spécialisés donc
c'est un combat en particulier en
afrique où nous avons mis en place des
dispositifs de contraint fluence y
compris sur les réseaux sociaux pour
éviter cette dérive là ceux qui jouent
aujourd'hui sur le fait que en gros on
pourrait dire les anciens colonialistes
ne peuvent pas prétendre à être nos
acteurs du développement dans le pays
ce texte est ce refrain là est assez
parfois repris par un certain nombre de
puissances qui veulent s'installer dans
les pays où nous avons de l'influencé
c'est pour ça que je commençais mon
propos tout à l'heure par dire que le
l'influencent était un outil de
puissance mais c'est aussi le
développement c'est un outil de
développement des valeurs et ça rentre
dans la config qualité des modèles
auxquels nous sommes confrontés
aujourd'hui dans le monde entier
c'est une forme de conclusion
[Musique]